let's finish off this table
to finish it off properly though
we need to understand something else so
underneath where you've got the table
would you make this new little
subheading for me
kinds of
data okay
now all the different things that we've
looked at right all the different kinds
of data hair length
heart rate how long you could hold your
breath
even number of siblings and so on they
were all numbers they're all numbers
okay so we have a big name that covers
this whole area of data
because you can call these numbers like
a quantity right
we call it quantitative data right it
can be quantified you can put a
numerical value on
it okay
now
when you go within numbers and i'm
particularly going to look at group four
because they did the siblings right you
will notice that there's more than one
kind of numerical data okay
most of us how i was called continuous
quantitative data continuous numerical
data so the idea is that there's range
right and any value in there
they're all fair game you can take um
any value between this and this
and you'll get a reasonable answer okay
so this usually comes from when you
measure things like someone's hairlet
okay
however that's not the only kind of
quantitative data right you can also
have the opposite of continuous which
you might think is called discontinuous
but not quite it has its own special
fancy name
discrete
quantitative data okay not to be
confused with
discrete with a double e
which means sh quiet secret discrete
that's what that discrete means
this discrete comes from a latin word
which means separate and they're all you
know they're not continuous they're not
connected you can only have certain
values for instance how many siblings
might you have
you might have none or one or two or
three but you can't have
one and a half siblings or one point two
five six
okay
so
continuous data comes from measurement
discrete data usually comes from
counting native questions um it's
discreet like this verse
hmm
that's a good question i don't think it
is but you can look up the etymology of
just before you go find out it's
possible so does that mean
medium i would probably say medium was
better it's not a clear-cut case you
made a good argument for why yeah
i don't know i necessarily agree with it
but here's my point see this is the
thing right
it's up in the air okay let's move on
now this is where we're starting to
connect to this okay
you can probably imagine there's not
just quantitative data data that you
want to know about people that you can
put in terms of a number okay
the other kind of data is called
categorical
categorical data
the short way of saying it of
understanding is it's any kind of
quality or attribute or value
that you can't say is a number you need
words to describe it
for instance
your favorite color
right what's your favorite color the 35
no that doesn't make sense right you'd
have to name something you'd have to use
words
categories okay
now just like with quantitative data
there's more than one kind of
categorical data if i said colors for
instance okay that would be called
nominal data right it has a name to it
right there are words there and there's
no inherent order that's the important
thing which one comes first blue or red
well it kind of doesn't matter it
doesn't you can put it in any order you
like
so things like i'll give you the example
of colors
okay
nominal categorical data it's words but
you can't order them
ordinal as the name suggests there are
some words that can be ordered okay so
for example i'll give you some letters
and i'll see if you recognize them and
they're in a specific order okay
um
yep
oh what's the next one i wrote it down
just so make sure i got it right there
we go
and then hopefully you never see that
one does anyone recognize where these
letters come from you see them about
twice a year
these letters appear on your
reports right this is part of the
personal profile there's some
categorical data there these stand for
words do you know what the words are yes
what does c stand for
consistently u4 usually s for
sometimes are for rarely
and for never
so there's an order here right
the order matters right so fair
yeah yes it really does okay so you can
see here
there's still words they're not numbers
but there is an order to them
so now i wonder if you can answer for me
what's the advantage of using a mode why
would you ever use the mode when is it
handy when is it useful
any thoughts
thinking about what we've just looked at
over here
well let me ask you this
since no one's jumping up and down
if we had some of these right like if um
i asked you to go and collect favorite
color okay or i looked at all of your
reports and we looked at all the
different outcomes that you received
okay
which one of these would be the best
measure of central tendency right
for instance suppose we're in color and
i said well i like taking the mean i
like taking the average okay
what is the average
of colors or how do you how do you rank
them right or what would be the middle
color does that even make sense right so
when you've got words
you have no choice really but to use the
mode okay so the key advantage of the
mode
is that wrong color
it um it works with categorical data
whereas you cannot really effectively
use the mean or the median if you have
words for your data okay so it works
with categorical data
the average favorite color is what gray
which is but not that's not very
meaningful is it
oh sorry um yeah okay
okay all right
i'll give you a quick two two
disadvantages under here there's more
but it just gives you a general juice um
number one and you might have a look at
your data okay
you can find out
no surprises to find out that the the
function in excel to find out the mode
is equals mode
right no surprises there okay
uh but the problem is sometimes there
isn't one right the mode might not exist
because for instance let's think about
hair length right
how likely is it that you've got people
in the class who have exactly the same
maximum healing right
not very likely it's possible
but not very likely okay
and secondly it ignores a lot of data
right i'll give you
a quick drawing which i'd like you to
sketch up just on the side of here to
illustrate this okay
suppose we had a graph
of let's go let's do hair length okay so
i'm just going to make up an imaginary
class okay and this is
hold on
wrong way sorry this is how many people
this is people
and this is hairline
okay so you've got longer hair going
this way shorter hair going this way
okay there's a whole bunch of number of
boys right who have relatively short
hair okay so suppose you know this is
say 10 okay and you've got 10 people up
here
right
but then you have a whole bunch of girls
and we've got here sort of you know one
person here one person here one person
here one person you one person here okay
now when you have a look at this where
is the mode it's really obvious where
the mode is right
it's all the way over there on the left
for whatever short length of hair this
is okay
how much has the mode taken into account
all of those girls up the top end with
really long hair answer it hasn't not at
all completely ignore them okay so
therefore that's kind of a problem right
the mode can get thrown off in a similar
way to the mean cancer you have to be
careful with it all right